I want to give you a new perspective
that sounds grandiose and it is I left
Ireland yesterday morning
I traveled from Dublin to New York
independently but the design of an
airport plane in terminal offers little
independence when you're 100 and five
and a half centimeters tall for
Americans that's three feet five inches
I was whisked through the airports by
airline assistants in a wheelchair now I
don't need to use a wheelchair but the
design of an airport and its lack of
accessibility means that it's my only
way to get through with my carry-on bag
between my feet I was wheeled through
security preclearance and I arrived at
my boarding gate I use the accessibility
services in the airport because most of
the terminal is just not designed with
me in mind take security for example I'm
not strong enough to lift my carry-on
bag from the ground to the carousel i
standard I level with it and those who
work in that space for safety purposes
kind of helped me and cannot do it for
me
design inhibits my autonomy and my
independence but traveling at this size
it isn't all that the legroom in economy
is like business class I often forget
that I'm a little person it's the
physical environment and society that
remind me using a public bathroom is an
excruciating experience I walk into the
cubicle but I can't reach the lock on
the door I'm creative and resilient I
look around and see if there's a bin my
can turn upside down is it safe
not really
is it hygienic and sanitary definitely
not but the alternative is much worse if
that doesn't work I use my phone
it gives me an additional four to six
inch reach and I try to jam the lock
closed with my iPhone now I imagine
that's not what Johnny I had in mind
when he designed the iPhone but it works
the alternative is that I approach a
stranger I apologize profusely and I ask
them to stand guard outside my cubicle
door they do and I emerged grateful but
absolutely mortified and hope that they
didn't notice that I left the bathroom
without washing my hands
I carry hand sanitizer with me every
single day because the sink soap
dispenser hand dryer and mirror are all
out of my reach now the accessible
bathroom is somewhat of an option in
this space I can reach the lock on the
door the sink the soap dispenser a hand
dryer and the mirror yes I cannot use
the toilet it is deliberately designed
higher so that wheelchair users can
transfer across with ease this is a
wonderful and necessary innovation but
in the design world when we describe a
new project or idea as accessible what
does that mean
who is it accessible to and whose needs
are not being accommodated for now the
bathroom is an example of where design
impinges upon my dignity but the
physical environment impacts upon me and
much more casual ways to something as
simple as ordering a cup of coffee now
I'll admit I drink far too much coffee
my order is a skinny vanilla latte but
I'm trying to wean myself off the syrup
but the coffee shop it's not designed
well at least not for me
queueing I'm standing beside the pastry
cabinet and the barista calls for the
next order nextly
is they shout they can't see me the
person next to me the cube points to my
existence and everyone is embarrassed I
order as quick as I can and they move
along to collect my coffee they sink
just for a second where do they put us
up high and would ever lid reaching your
particular after coffee that I have paid
for is incredibly dangerous experience
but design also impinges on the clothes
that I want to wear I want garments that
reflect my personality it's difficult to
find in the children's word apparent and
often women's wear requires far too many
alterations
I want shoes that affect my maturity
professionalism and sophistication
instead I'm offered sneakers with velcro
straps and light-up shoes now I'm not
totally opposed to lots of shoes but
design also impacts on such simple
things like sitting on a chair I cannot
go from a standing to a seating position
with grace due to the de standards of
design heights of chairs I have to crawl
on my hands and knees just to get on top
this well it's also being conscious that
it might tip over at any stage but was
design impacts upon me whether it's a
chair a bathroom a coffee shop or
clothes I rely on and benefit from the
kindness of strangers but not everybody
is so nice I'm reminded that I'm a
little person when a stranger points
stairs
laughs calls me a name or takes a
photograph of me this happens almost
every day with the rise of social media
has given me an opportunity and a
platform to have a voice as a blogger
and as an activist but it has also made
me nervous that I might become a meme or
a viral sensation or without my consent
so let's take a moment
right now to make something very clear
the word midges is a slur it evolved
from PT Barnum's era of circuses and
freak shows society has evolved so
should our vocabulary language is a
powerful tool it does not just name our
society it shapes it I am incredibly
proud to be a little person to have
inherited the condition of
achondroplasia but I am most proud to be
sinead achondroplasia is the most common
form of dwarfism achondroplasia
translates as without cartilage
formation I have short limbs and
achondroplastic facial features my
forehead and my nose my arms do not
straighten fully but I can lick my elbow
I'm not showing you that one
achondroplasia occurs in approximately
one in every twenty thousand births 80%
of little people are wanted to average
highs parents that means that anybody in
this room could have a child with
achondroplasia yes I inherited my
condition from my dad I'd like to show
you a photo of my family my mother is
average height my father is a little
person and I am the eldest of five
children I have three sisters and one
brother they are all average height I am
incredibly fortunate to have been born
into a family that cultivated my
curiosity and my tenacity that protected
me from the unkindness and ignorance of
strangers and that armed me with the
resilience creativity and confidence
that I needed to survive and manipulate
the physical environment and society if
I was to pinpoint any reason why I am
successful is because I was and I am a
loved child now I love trials with a lot
of sass and sarcasm but I love childs
nonetheless in giving you an insight
into
Who I am today I wanted to offer you a
new perspective I wanted to challenge
the idea that design has brought a tool
to create function and beauty design
greatly impacts upon people's lives all
lives design is a way in which we can
feel included in the world but it is
also a way in which we can uphold a
person's dignity and their human rights
design can also inflict vulnerability on
a group whose needs aren't considered so
today I wondered perceptions challenged
who are we not designing for how can we
amplify their voices and their
experiences what is the next step design
is an enormous privilege but it is a
bigger responsibility I want you to open
your eyes thank you so much
[Applause]